look I did this again just to help to
understand what's going on right most
people find addition a lot easier than
subtraction okay and it's just kind of
less error-prone which is why rather
doing this is this graph in this graph
I've been to the difference I'm graphic
this graph in this graph and I'm doing
the song okay you can do it either way
but well see how your brain goes okay so
therefore I've got them there and what
I'm doing is adding okay I'm thinking
about these ordinates up and down those
values and I'm going to something right
now some points as your notice are
easier than others right there's one
glaring the easy point that you can pick
their lees 0 right so at the origin both
components as you value of x and the
negative as you lay of 2x they're both
people to 0 so you add their ornaments
and there you go you get 0 to take shape
okay know what can I add to this right
now i'll give you a bit of a hint right
how do I look at how two components
right the absolute value of x as a
function think back to what you're doing
you know all of your curve sketching
just your regular curve sketching what
kind of symmetry does the absolute value
X have what kind of function is it it's
an even function right because you've
got this reflective symmetry and cross
the x-axis the absolute value of
negative the absolute value of 2x also
an even function right so therefore when
you add or subtract two even functions
you're going to get another even
function okay so i'm going to be super
cheap as all mathematicians should
strive to me and i'm just going to do
one side of this i need to do one side
once I've got that side I just reflected
across okay mathematicians famously lazy
taken mind on it now I've got this i'm
gonna go to the right okay pick an
ordinate again pick it easy one what
would you like x equals x equals one
super easy I mean pick a hard one if you
want but I'm not going to do that on the
board and x equals 1 I know exactly what
this graph is equal to its one whats the
apps
about 11 ok so if I put that there
that's fine now the order that that
corresponds to that down here is going
to be negative a 0 u 2 which is negative
to see about one you've got negative to
you add them together that gives you
negative 1 right so there you go there's
one or a busy on something looking like
something over here ok now this doesn't
take too much logic to extend once I go
to 2 i've got 2 and negative 4 right so
when you put them together you're going
to get negative 2 in fact you're going
to get all the points on the line y
equals negative x all the way down this
way ok so having got the right hand side
I don't need to apply any more effort to
look at left hand side I just fit them
across ok and I get this graph in fact
the exempt craft that I guess is why he
goes negative the absolute value X ok
now this is kind of interesting because
usually we look at these we say hey
don't mess around with those absolute
values don't you leaving where they are
and they don't mix together ok we can
mix them together in this special case
because look x they were 2x negative x
right because these to share the same
domain for when they switch over right
they both switch over x equals 0 so
being that this one switches from
negative x to x and this one switch is
over from 2 x 2 negative 2 eggs at
exactly the same point you can just put
them together you just get a new piece
malfunction with the same